If you haven't seen him live and heard him live...
...and you just hear that there's a young kid who can play jazz,...
...there's no way to prepare you for what you're going to experience...
...until you actually see it happen.
He's listening to everything that's happening.
He plays with dynamics.
He comes in with fully formed arrangements of tunes that he's thought of.
And he also comes in totally open to changing or forgetting those arrangements...
...and coming up with new ones.
Everything that Ulysses and I played, he was reacting to,...
...which is what I get from the greatest musicians.
It's so natural for him.
He hears it the way we hear, like, English vocabulary...
...where you like, learn a new word.
He learns it.
He doesn't only just learn material.
Joey understands then how to use the material in a musical way.
It's amazing when we play, like, I hear so many different influences.
Maybe I'd love a mentor while I'm still learning every day.
Well, that's music.
You have to keep doing what you do.
While playing, my brain transforms. My heart transforms. Technique or anything is from the heart,...
...and that's jazz: it's from the groove.